we haven't quite hit April yet but a
little slip-up has already given us a
peek at the next lineup of free
PlayStation Plus games if you are a
subscriber and want to know what you can
grab in the new month I've got you
covered
first up on ps4 is uncharted 4 a thief's
end the Nathan Drake collection was part
of PS Plus recently so now you can
finish the story with Drake's final
chapter
this adventure once again sees him Sully
Elena and the rest of the gang searching
for treasure all over the world and this
time they're joined by Nathan's
estranged brother Sam ps4s other free
game will also take you all over the
world dirt rally 2.0 features tracks in
all sorts of countries and varying
weather conditions means you'll have to
change your driving style depending on
the forecast rally racing isn't just
about flooring at at all times no matter
which of the game's 50 cars you drive
this PS Plus lineup was revealed in a
Playstation access YouTube video that is
now private so if anything changes we'll
be sure to mention it on GameSpot
presumably these games will be available
from April 7th through May 4th stay
tuned as we report on the new PS Plus
lineup every month
[Music]